what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with secret Invasion now I know
it's been a little slow up to this point
but this is when everything takes off so
what we do here is we initially pick up
with Tony Stark meeting with Reed
Richards and Hank Pym now here's the
thing the way the Tony Stark talks to
Reed Richards and simply saying that
like you and Hank Pym are the smartest
like two of the smartest men in the
world and that's why I'm bringing this
to you Reid Richards is surprised by the
fact that like Elektra is a scroll now
those are the guys who have followed are
covered so far Reed Richards already
knows this because he's a member of the
Fantastic Four and he's a member of the
Illuminati so pray tell why Reid
Richards is surprised in this story to
learn that Elektra is a scroll because
Brian Michael bindis is writing it and
if you don't know anything about Marvel
Comics this is something that you need
to be aware of Ryan Michael bindis is
notorious for two things putting way
more text in a comic than he needs to
and ignoring stuff sometimes Ryan
Michael Bendis will ignore the things he
wrote which this is a perfect example of
it the alternative is the excuse that we
as fans made up which is that Reed
Richards is pretending because nobody's
supposed to know he's a member of the
Illuminati so in front of Hank Pym he's
acting like oh man this is crazy I can't
believe something like this happened
good thing I didn't know about it
beforehand because now I could do
whatever it is that I need to do in
order to find some way to stop this it's
the only way that we know how to
rationalize it as fans that's why a lot
of us were just really excited when
Bendis left and went to DC and then he
screwed up Superman but the thing about
this is that once that Revelation is
brought forward this switches over to
the peak because Stark bringing this to
the the attention of Reed and Hank Pym
is that they can put their minds to task
and they can figure out how it is that
Elektra was able to be replaced by a
scroll and that scroll was able to avoid
the detection of virtually everybody but
for those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with the peak this is the main base of
operations for the sentient World
observation and response department now
this group is similar to Shield but not
directly so sword was created out of
Shield that if Shield monitors the
various threats that exist on Earth then
Shield came to the realization and
really even Nick Fury himself came into
the realization there needs to be an
organization that monitors threats in
space hence the reason why sword was
born and that's literally what they do
they just monitor as much of space as
they possibly can because they can't see
it all and they basically keep an eye on
whatever threats may be approaching
earth right so like if Galactus is
coming to Earth sword will know about it
and then they'll just have to evacuate
because there's basically nothing they
can do but that's the thing to kind of
keep in mind here but sword is a very
strategic operation and being able to
understand what threats exist out there
that could potentially be targeting
Earth the kicker about all this is they
pick up on basically an object or a ship
making its way towards Earth and what's
really crazy about this is Iron Man
immediately takes off and then contacts
the mighty Avengers to have them respond
as well as Luke Cage there's a couple
things to understand here when it comes
to this segment first and foremost the
reason why Luke Cage is against this and
the reason why his team is referred to
as The Secret Avengers is because in the
aftermath of Civil War when basically
Iron Man won and he became the new
director of shield and the 50 state
initiative was invoked and superhuman
registration became the law of the land
you had two things that happened the
first is that most all of the Avengers
basically went underground they
abandoned the entire role because they
didn't want to have anything to do with
registration and they steadily stood
fast against it but the other part of
this is that with most of the Avengers
basically leaving Tony Stark Tony Stark
took those Avengers that were on his
side and seeing it as kind of a fresh
start so to speak basically created the
mighty Avengers and so the mighty
Avengers that's the heavy hitting team
right that's like Carol Danvers that's
the God of War Aries it's the century
Robert Reynolds more than enough to
handle virtually any threat that could
show up on Earth outside of just some
crazy level Cosmic entity like Galactus
but they're pretty Heavy Hitters the
kicker about all this is that in order
for The Secret Avengers to basically get
to where it is that this ship is Crash
Landing at they basically travel to
Avengers Tower they still the
Helicarrier steal the The Vessel of Tony
Stark and then race off now of course
Tony Stark could basically shut it down
remotely so of course they basically
deactivated right they deactivate the
motherboard so they can basically just
travel to wherever it is they need to
travel to and that's it without having
to worry about Tony Stark shutting it
down but the reality here is they
ultimately end up arriving in the Savage
land and they get there at least shortly
after they arrive there Iron Man arrives
as well now the fact that these guys are
all Secret Avengers they defy the whole
role of like superhero registration all
that kind of stuff that's the reason why
Tony Stark wants to arrest them right
because of the fact that they're
literally vigilantes in the eyes of the
law and so you do have a bit of a
skirmish that kind of breaks out between
them where literally it's superhero
facing off against superhero to a degree
it's more of a standoff than anything
else but while that's going on it's all
being monitored by Abigail brand and
sword and that's when dum dum Dugan who
has historically been one of Shield's
top agents and is really kind of a field
advisor here on sword when it's revealed
that he's a scroll and when Luke Cage
pries open this ship basically rips open
the door it sets off an alarm and that
basically tells dum dum Dugan to make
his move at which point he blows up the
peak he literally destroys the sword
base now this is huge because what this
does is it basically removes Earth's
ability to recognize any potential
threats coming from space they won't
know anything right I mean there's
satellite systems and things like that
but the other part of this and it's
really like a multi-faceted strike and
it's a genius maneuver by the Scrolls
what they also do is Jarvis who has
always been like the butler of the
Avengers in the MCU he's an AI created
by Tony Stark in Marvel Comics he's a
literal guy like he's a physical guy an
actual Butler that basically exists out
there but what happens is he literally
uploads a virus to basically the
Avengers database which allows it to not
just affect like Tony Stark but the rest
of the world as well but what it does is
it shuts down the armor of Tony Stark
right so now Tony Stark's entire armor
system is nullified and it's not just
that armor it's every suit of armor he
has there's no redundancies anymore
there's no backups no nothing right like
it's just Tony Stark without any
technology at his disposal it's
basically the Scrolls launching a
multi-pronged strike against the Earth
shutting down virtually every
technological system they have and in
fact this whole attack is so intense
that Maria Hill who basically is the
kind of interim director of Shield at
the moment with Tony Stark basically off
out in the field that she's literally
like this is a Mayday this is an SOS we
have just complete and total
communication failure and she literally
tells everybody on the Helicarrier
abandoned [ __ ] and the reason why is
because the Helicarrier has been shut
down and it's just crashing into the
city of New York right literally getting
ready to crash land the other part of
this strike is it takes down the
satellite systems of the United States
and really the world as a whole so
there's no detection systems whatsoever
the entire technological stance of the
Earth has been reverted back a few
hundred years but to make everything
just to really put the cherry on top the
next part of this strike targets the
raft now for those of you guys who
aren't familiar with the raft this was
actually the first story that was done
by Brian Michael Ben when he wrote New
Avengers but basically the raft is a
super villain prison and the most
extreme of these villains the molecule
man Owen Reese who can alter reality on
a on a universal scale people like that
right Victor Von Doom who's apparently
being held prisoner that they're all
held in the sub base with this virus
making its attack every single person
who's part of this base ends up getting
freed and so what it does is it switches
over to the Thunderbolts mountain now
for both the guys who are unfamiliar
with Thunderbolts mountain and this is a
pretty significant thing Thunderbolts
mountain is basically the the location
of Norman Osborne's Thunderbolts team
that you did have the Thunderbolts who
and who existed initially Thunderbolts
returned during Shield under the control
of Baron Zemo in Marvel Comics post
Civil War Thunderbolts had basically
been modified to where it was more of
like a Suicide Squad type team that
basically it's where super villains
would be held and they would be they
would operate as like agents trying to
quote unquote atone for their actions so
it still maintained that original
charter the difference here is that
under Norman Osborne this is going to
become ridiculously important in fact
Norman Osborne is going to prove to be
one of the most significant people if
not the most significant person that has
a hand in the events of secret Invasion
I'm not going to go super in depth into
that but you'll figure it out by the
time we get to the end but the other
part of this is we basically switch over
to the Fantastic Four and this shows you
just how extensive the Scrolls ability
to infiltrate Society is the Fantastic
Four has some of the most advanced
Security in the world so much so that
even with these attacks these strikes
Happening by the Scrolls and taking down
like multiple facets of Technology
across the world the Fantastic Four are
actually immune to it because of the
technological advancements of Reed
Richards that it basically allows them
to operate on kind of a redundant power
system outside of any sort of network
connection but Scrolls being as they are
in this story and being able to operate
undetected by any superheroes on Earth
it allows one of them to impersonate
Susan storm to enter into the Fantastic
Four and in doing so basically activate
the portal to the negative zone now the
reason why this is so huge those of you
guys who aren't familiar with that the
reason why this is big is because the
negative zone is composed of antimatter
right the positive the the Marvel
Multiverse as we know it is composed of
positive matter this is like an
Unstoppable Force meeting an immovable
object say for example this portal were
to just grow to the size of a universe
or something like that it would negate
the existence of the Multiverse as a
whole it would destroy everything now of
course the Scrolls aren't looking to
annihilate all existence across the
Multiverse they're simply looking to
make Earth uninhabitable but this is
them setting the stage because what it
does is it creates a distraction for the
Fantastic Four because it literally
starts sucking everything in around it
and so to really set things off here and
what's really really Bonkers is that
once the heroes back in the Savage land
right where the vessel had basically
crashed that what this does is it
basically shows that like all these
different variations of the Avengers
start a emerging from this ship you have
like the X-Men you've got like the the
main Avengers roster itself and you even
have just Heroes that kind of exist out
there right people like Luke Cage and so
on and so forth the funny thing about
this is that they're all for the most
part wearing older costumes and so it's
literally the older superheroes meeting
the newer superheroes the reason why
that's such a huge deal is because of
the fact that these guys emerge and
start talking like they've been
kidnapped this whole time right they
they're like oh my God it's so good to
finally make it back home and so what it
does is it starts to kind of beg this
question who's actually a scroll here is
it like the superheroes who have just
been on Earth this whole time is it the
superheroes who are arriving on Earth
from like this scroll ship and I know
that on the surface right now it's like
well it's obvious the ones who arrived
on Earth from the ship are Scrolls the
things are going to get a lot more
complicated and a lot Messier but when
you switch back over to the Stark lab
where you have Reed Richards and you
have uh Hank Pym that basically Reed
Richards figures out how it is the
scrolls are able to basically operate
without being detected by telepathy or
any of that stuff and as soon as he
turns to Hank Pym and tells him that
it's revealed that Hank Pym is a scroll
who basically incapacitates Reed
Richards and then just kind of leaves it
there right so what this does here and
this is this is a pretty significant
thing what this does here is it switches
over to the main Thunderbolts themselves
now under any normal circumstance I
probably wouldn't cover this just
because of the fact that it's like okay
I mean it's cool you know but like I
said Norman Osborne is going to be a
huge player by the time he gets to the
end of this story and in fact it's going
to set the stage for a whole bunch of
stuff that comes after but what
basically goes on here is basically
Marvel attacks thunderbolt's mountain
now here's the thing to understand
Marvel's dead right this guy's dead so
obviously this Marvel is either one to
somehow return to life or he's a scroll
the reality is that he's a scroll right
I mean we're not really going to follow
his story anymore over the course of
this video series so we can just kind of
throw it there but the reality here is
that it takes the entirety of
thunderbolts Mountain by surprise one
because of the fact that this attack was
lost and two because Marvel died of
cancer it was actually a huge Landmark
story that Marvel wrote back in 1984 by
Jim Starlin I think but it was basically
called the death of Captain Marvel the
guy died of cancer and it was one of the
first times in Marvel Comics when they
introduced a means by which a superhero
could die and there's no conceivable way
of saving their life there was no way to
stop the cancer in Marvel's body I mean
I guess you could have right like here's
The Infinity Gauntlet let's just fix him
right but I'm pretty sure on the story
they nullified all possible options and
he'd even made peace with it and was
just kind of like okay it's cool right
it's my time to go that sort of thing
and basically just moved on but Marvel
was immensely powerful right he had the
ability to manipulate Cosmic radiation
which made him just hugely capable now a
lot of this was because of the mega
bands different things like that that he
used but the fact is he overtakes the
entirety of the Thunderbolts team and so
once the whole team is basically
defeated it leads to Norman Osborne
basically stepping up and saying hey man
so like you literally just trashed the
entirety of my of my whole Mountain do
you want to sit down and have a
conversation with it so I know that this
is one of those things where it doesn't
seem overly important it seems wildly
unnecessary it'll become very important
later on down the line but jumping back
into the main secret Invasion story that
what it does is picking up in the Savage
land again on one side you have like we
can we can call them like the modern
superheroes and we can call the other
ones like the older superheroes right
just to kind of differentiate between
the two and make it easier to keep track
of everything the modern superheroes are
absolutely certain of the fact that they
are human beings who have lived on Earth
this entire time the older superheroes
believe the exact same thing that they
are those superheroes as you can imagine
it creates a huge sense of confusion now
one of the things that happens here is
there's a few tips that you get right
from the modern Avengers who are like
this is obviously not the Avengers team
these guys are Scrolls one because like
Captain America is there right by this
point in time in Marvel Comics Captain
America had already been shot and killed
by agent 13 right like he was already
dead and out of the picture and so it's
one of those things where like the fact
that he's here doesn't really make any
sense unless that Captain America who
died was actually a scroll but his body
never reverted so he stayed human the
whole time whenever a scroll dies they
revert back to their scroll form so that
indicates this Captain America is not
actually a scroll and that kind of gives
the rest of the team license to believe
that all the old superheroes are Scrolls
and that they as the modern superheroes
are actual humans but this is when stuff
starts to get murky because some of the
Scrolls overplay their hand for example
one of the Scrolls starts talking to
Robert Reynolds now the reality here is
this is just Brian Michael Bendis
getting Sentry out of the way because if
we're being honest with ourselves that
guy's powerful enough to end the
conflict like that right he could just
end it just in an instant but remember
the alter ego of Robert Reynolds is the
void right it's his evil Persona and the
part of himself that he's always trying
to keep at Bay and so when the vision
when when older Vision attacks Robert
Reynolds he actually tells him Robert
Reynolds you did all this right lest we
forget your alternate ego right the void
has the ability to alter reality and I
am the void and I did all this because
you wanted it to you wanted it to happen
subconsciously and it basically sees
Robert Reynolds take away it's stupid
don't get me wrong it's ridiculously
stupid right it would be really really
cool to see Sentry here here's one of
the things to know about Robert Reynolds
and Marvel Comics it's usually whenever
he shows up it's pointless because a
writer will bring him in and then
immediately write him out because the
writer will realize oh my God this guy's
way too powerful to be here we got to
somehow get him out of the story and
call it a day and that's exactly what
happens here because the century is
basically Marvel's Superman outside of
like Hyperion right like the century and
Hyperion are just two of the physically
strongest characters that exist in
Marvel Comics and in fact the Century's
Gone toe-to-toe With The Incredible Hulk
multiple times and in fact the
Incredible Hulk is scared of the Void
because of how powerful he is so it's
just one of those things to know the
kind of a funny circumstance here is
again at this point in time in Marvel
Comics Hawkeye is operating as Ronin you
guys may remember him from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but the thing about
this is that he he observes more than
anything else that he basically subdues
his older counterpart and then takes off
in the woods to watch and that's one of
the things to know about Hawkeye when it
comes to how he was written following
his return in the aftermath of House of
M that basically he just kind of
observes and watches things that he
doesn't really engage a whole lot in any
of these events but it's just one of
those things where he just kind of sees
what's going on now Carol Danvers ends
up getting Tony Stark to safety but
that's when you start to see the reality
of the situation starting to really hone
in and box people in that Tony Stark
tells Carol Danvers okay look all of my
suits are gone so I'm going to use the
one thing the Scrolls can't duplicate
which is my brain I'm literally gonna
have to rebuild an Iron Man suit from
scratch because in the Savage land you
do have forms of technology it was used
by Magneto as a base of operations at
one point it's been used by other people
they've brought technology there they've
done experiments different things like
that and so while this technology here
in the Savage land is nowhere near as
modern or fancy as Tony's Stark's normal
Tech it is enough for him to get the job
done but Carol Danvers in hearing this
starts to kind of question whether or
not Tony Stark is a scroll and that's
when you switch over to like Wolverine
encountering Luke Cage Wolverines the
exact same way that Luke Cage is like
hey man it's cool it's me like I'm I'm
just regular Luke Cage and Wolverines
like I don't care like I don't care if
you're a Luke Cage I don't care if you
say you're a Luke Cage I can't trust you
and in fact Wolverine's going to attack
him now the response of Luke Cage is
dude I have indestructible skin your
claws cannot hurt my skin and the
response of Wolverine is well then I got
an indestructible claws so I guess at
the moment we're just kind of an impasse
and like we'll just sort of call it a
day but the the version of Spider-Man
the older Spider-Man is basically just
kind of laying there in the aftermath of
everything that had happened he was
killed by Hawkeye and is basically
released reverts back into a scroll and
so because that is one of those things
where Hawkeye just kind of keeps an eye
on the situation but you have older
Hawkeye who's a scroll who's basically
been killed by Mockingbird and as he
lays dying Wolverine comes to this real
that what's actually going on here with
these Scrolls is they genuinely believe
they're these Heroes right that's the
reason why they were able to operate
undetected is because these guys who
were Scrolls either don't know they were
Scrolls or they had their mind modified
in such a way to where they genuinely
believe they are these Heroes and that's
why Wolverine draws this conclusion and
saying all the older superheroes are
Scrolls if they emerge from that ship
they are Scrolls and that's when he goes
racing over to Mockingbird Bobby Morris
with the intention of killing her now at
that point modern Hawkeye steps in and
says no no no you're not gonna kill her
and it's like it's one of those things
where he's like we have to put her to a
test right we have to test whether or
not she's actually Mockingbird so I'm
going to ask her a question if she can
answer this question then that means
that she's actually who she claims to be
and what he does is he says tell me
about October 12th and that's what we
end up learning that Bobby Morse that
mockingbird was pregnant at one point in
time and she ended up having a
miscarriage and never told told anybody
but October 12th is when their kid was
going to be born having mapped out like
the actual day of that child's birth and
it would have been a beautiful day and
literally Hawkeye takes out his evidence
enough to just kind of be like okay
because in his mind he's like you died
right like this baby that we were gonna
have like you died so so like one it was
a miscarriage then you were dead so like
it seemed like there was no conceivable
way to put this together but using those
two things Hawkeye's just like it's
definitely Mockingbird right it's
definitely her but that's where the
seeds of Doubt are being planted because
the question here is is this actually
Mockingbird right is it actually her and
like she was taken by the Scrolls or
whatever it is she was held prisoner for
any number of reasons and she's actually
arrived here on Earth and she is an
actual human so this vessel contained a
combination of humans and Scrolls or is
she an actual scroll and it's just the
memories of Mockingbird were put into
her head and she genuinely believes
she's that person that's where the seeds
of Doubt come into play that's where the
question really gets answered who's a
human and who's a scroll who do you
trust and so it's kind of a last ditch
action here what ends up happening is
that while the Fantastic Four are
distracted what the Negative Zone portal
being open and trying to find some way
to shut it down to scroll vessels starts
showing up and when they do what you end
up getting is this colossal scroll
invasion of all these different Scrolls
who all basically have any combination
of superheroes that you can conceivably
imagine they're launching their main
strike because the whole goal of the
Scrolls here is to keep the superheroes
distracted to keep them removed from the
landscape and then it's just mop up Duty
with the average person just wiping out
and annihilating all the just regular
denizens of Earth so by the time the
superheroes come back or at least
they're able to deal with their
Circumstance the Scrolls can take out
most of them and that actual invading
Army that we see here will just take out
the rest but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later
peace